[Music]
let's talk about your downtime you spend
a lot of time in the country in the
country I do yeah and I have goats your
goats
I have dwarf goats it started well
donkeys were the fantasy for me really
nobody made you say that a lot of time
in your camper on movies and I spent a
lot of time on this site donkey rescue
calm you get invested in the donkeys oh
it's right where you rest your donkeys
yes personality profiles like Jed is a
social and loyal ass who spends they
can't ever be alone and you have to get
to you can't get one donkey you have to
get two so it was really into the idea
of having two donkeys right and the fact
that they were a lonely animal kind of
understand okay so you're interested in
donkeys that was the dream and then
these were the dream and then I left
with
and you said they're dwarf games worth
goats they're small right yeah there's
really cuddly though so and you how many
of these dwarf goats do you have my
neighbor and I we share them now you
share these with your neighbor
okay is it true there's a goat that you
can make a loud noise in it faints and
falls open wouldn't that be a useful
skill yeah people
you mean if people had it oh god if you
were on a date or like recently I can
thank you know and you can just like
faint
that's called narcolepsy just think if
you're in a situation you don't like and
you're on a date and the guy you went on
a date recently that you weren't
enjoying yourself you could just live
and he's fall over right right did the
guy know it was a bad date unclear
really do you want to talk about this
anymore
really
what makes me want to know much more
I'll tell you on the break you'll tell
me in the break stay on a break good and
then I'll come back and tell everyone
what you said